all
right welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics um I have two um announcements
first uh please mute yourself during the
talk but if you have question you can
unmute and ask questions or use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in Q&A session
and finally today's ddps seminar is open
to external
audiences um therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out uh that's about it now let me
briefly introduce our speaker today it
is an honor to host Dr yasaman Bari who
is a research scientist at Google Deep
Mind with research interest at the
interface of statistical physics machine
learning and condens matter physics in
recent years she has worked on the
foundations of deep learning from a
physics perspective she has been an
invited lecturer at the last hter school
of physics and was a co-organizer of a
recent program at the kav institute for
theoretical physics previously she
received a PhD in physics at UC Berkeley
today yasaman will talk about a first
first principle approach to
understanding deep learning I'm sure we
are going to hear a wonderful talk now
um let me ask a somewhat informal
questions to yesen just to get to know
you better yesen so my question as I uh
warn you uh will be you have a very
interesting background you you have a
physics major pure physics major I
assume yes and then now you are uh in
you know computational science and
specifically the machine learning and AI
how did it
happen it happened uh somewhat
organically so my my PhD thesis was
indeed on um kind of pure physics and
theoretical physics in um Quantum
condens matter physics um but condensed
matter physics has a long history of um
condensed matter physicists have a long
history of kind of going into other
disciplines and there's really a broad
notion of what constitutes condense
matter physics um um it turns out that
in the past uh historically condensed
matter physicists have also studied um
neural networks as a part of the study
of disordered systems and that's
something that you kind of was alluded
to in the Nobel Prize in physics uh that
was awarded this year um I got
interested in it organically while I was
still at Berkeley um I kind of started
to go to seminars in the computer
science department and heard about all
this and at that time all of the um
empirical advancements and and um at
that time uh there uh um something that
kind of came to the for was it a lot of
people saying that it would how
important it would be to try to
understand at least something about what
these models are doing um and so um that
as a scientific problem is how I got
started in the field and so I kind of uh
worked on that problem um a bit more
from like a physics angle either with
methods from physics or physics flavored
um types of questions um and then more
recently I've kind of uh wanted to also
explore kind of go back a bit into um uh
applications of of machine learning to
um uh to areas of the sciences that I
know like condensed matter materials um
molecular systems and that's more of a
uh more recent development that I won't
talk about um but kind of bringing them
back together and that second part is uh
partly also I think inspired by a lot of
the advancements I've seen um now having
worked at um Deep Mind or Google first
Google brain and Deep Mind for some time
um just seeing those advancements and
what they can
do nice nice well um yes as you said uh
the first Nobel prize from the the mine
learning um person uh from the Nobel
Prize fedics and I I hope that's going
to happen more often and someday maybe
yasam and you you are going to be a
Nobel Prize recipient from the physics
field okay the stage is yours okay thank
you Yu for the kind um introduction and
the
invitation um so the the focus of this
talk will really be um as the title says
taking a first principles approach to
trying to understand deep learning so
rather than talk about methods
specifically from the physical sciences
I'd like to just give a little bit of a
survey or overview of some of my work
and more broadly things that would be
interesting for scientists who work with
datadriven methods in general and and um
and how at least there's been some
progress made in understanding some
pieces of this big landscape of um you
know big design space of neural networks
and AI where there are just so many
knobs and so many choices to make at
least something about some of that has
been understood recently and I'd like to
share a little bit of that with you um
in in hopes that it might um kind of
influence maybe your research uh in in
the physical sciences as well so um as
you all know you know there's this uh um
ever persistent promise of machine
learning and Ai and also some um real
successes uh from the past few years um
in in the Sciences uh as you know in
protein structure prediction like the
alpha fold model um in uh developing
neural network-based DFT functionals for
example um and as well as uh developing
increasingly large language models that
can do some amounts of math and science
reasoning um uh in certain domains in
certain types of
problems um so these have all been um
big advancements from uh big models in
the last few years um but I'm going to
now maybe take a different um angle to
in this talk which is uh what do we
understand about deep learning and how
it works and how to design models um and
um I would say along with all this
empirical progress that has happened I
feel the on the understanding side um
were uh quite a bit behind um and you
know just a few years ago at one of the
main ml major ml conferences uh you know
one of the invited speakers very
famously made this illusion that deep
learning is not really a science or in
engineering it's Alchemy it's just
mixing things you know um designing
models in a somewhat unprincipled way
without you know the designer knowing
exactly what will work or what won't and
having some basic principles um so I
think uh you know the unanticipated
success of using neural networks as
models uh forces us to consider some new
questions and also revisit some old ones
from just machine learning from the past
few decades so the types of questions I
want to kind of address in this talk are
what can we say about what neural
networks actually learn um if anything
at all um so this problem turns out to
be solvable in certain regimes which can
be useful um why is it that neural
networks with more and more parameters
perform better so there's been this
trend uh in the field to make a models
bigger and often either models wider or
wider and deeper uh and so on um and
this kind of runs counter to this old
intuition from um just statistics but as
as scientists uh when you think about
fitting um uh any data the more
parameters you use you worry about
overfitting and somehow this runs
completely counter um this this trend
runs completely counter to that and then
the third question is what controls the
gains from scaling up deep neural
networks as we increase the amount of
data or the size of the model uh and so
on so in the first part I just want to
give a bit of an overview of a topic
that I've worked on but that I think is
more broadly could be broadly useful to
um scientists who uh also do a lot of
scientific modeling um which is uh some
uh results some correspondences that we
built between neural networks and uh
gaussian processes which um I won't
describe in a lot of detail but maybe
some of you are familiar with um it's
sort of a very different modeling
Paradigm um to uh uh to uh the training
of neural
networks um so uh just to set up the
basic problem um uh let me consider a uh
just a vanilla neural network but we can
do this for a lot of different
architectures uh a fully connected deep
neural network which has a certain depth
L to the computation that it does and it
has a certain um hidden layer with n
which is essentially how many uh
computations it's doing in parallel at
the same time um and so uh we can
describe you know what the the
computation done by this network is a
recursion relationship where the
function f is a function of the original
input data X coming in um uh and we take
the signal f l minus one which is ALS a
function of X let's say at um coming in
here we pass it through a nonlinearity
fi we multiply by weight matrices uh
which are our learnable parameters in
this network and maybe a bias and uh we
do that to construct this um signal at
the next layer and this continues
through the through the
network so this computation um as I
mentioned it has a depth to it and it
has a network width um where here you uh
sum over um all these contributions from
the different hidden nodes or neurons
from the previous
layer um now in general being saying
being able to say something about this
computation is pretty challenging uh it
depends on a lot of the hyperparameters
but it turns out that at large n in this
um so when you take the limit of a large
number of um hidden nodes or neurons uh
the description of the system
simplifies um uh so you can kind of see
that through the central limit theorem
um and or or or um other more rigorous
techniques but essentially what happens
is at large n um uh you sum over uh very
many uh variables here um and that sum
you can uh when when you start with at
least at the at the beginning of
training a random Network um will
involve the sum over many random
variables and you can imagine how you
apply Central limit theorem to that um
to be able to describe the process F so
this kind of ties in basically it's uh
studying the statistical physics of
large and deep neural networks at the
moment just when they're randomly
initialized so we're just at we're you
can think of it at being at the
beginning of training we um initialize
the the the parameters uh randomly and
then we want to be able to describe the
system but I'll talk about training in
just a minute because it turns out we uh
you can just easily then um get to that
uh as well um so this is also you can
think of it as a type of mean field
theory that becomes exact uh in the
infinite width limit so the the the
conclusion is that at the large in the
large end limit when when the network wi
is wide enough this is well described by
a gaussian process this neural network
and uh what we need to describe Gan
process is just um a mean and aarian
function um so it's just described by
its low order
statistics so uh it turns out that
that's also pretty natural easy to
calculate so there's some recursion that
happens on the space of functions as you
uh go through one layer of the network
to another which I just described it's
this iterative
computation um but if you were going to
calculate the co variance function so
the expectation of f ofx * F ofx Prime
averaged over the network this is what
you need to be able to um describe the
uh to to construct the kernel function
of the gaussian process it turns out
that that also obeys a recursion
relation um so for from fnot you can
compute a kot from F1 you can compute a
K1 and so on until you get to a final K
this covariance function or kernel
function is a function of um two inputs
x and x Prime so just as a a a maybe
reminder so a gaussian process I
mentioned needs a mean function and a
covariance function the mean function in
the setting is just zero the coari
function is a function of two arguments
x and x prime it tells you roughly how
similar x and x Prime are after you
perform this series of
computations and there's a recursion
relationship that you can get for K that
exactly mirrors the one we wrote down
for f because it's done iteratively it
it it um uh inherits the uh computation
that the neural network uh inherently is
doing so this is a way um a a natural
way in which gaussian processes and
kernels arise from neural networks uh
naturally and they have a certain
structure that's different from kernels
or gausian processes that were known
before um because they have this
compositionality in them and you know
classic Yasin processes in in the
literature and textbooks if you look at
them um have a very different uh
structure they're usually constructed
from simpler functions and they're not
compositional in this way that I
described
so now that was the study of random
networks but once you map the problem
over to a gaussian process and that
description is exact as I mentioned in
that limit and it's a good description
if the layer width is large enough then
uh it's easy to do beian learning from
that um so if you have a data set D um
and you like to make beian predictions
from this neural network in this large
width limit you can essentially do that
through the gussian process um for
example uh so these are now well-
written you know uh kind of textbook
gaussian processes there are
equations uh that um you can look up for
what the prediction would be after
learning on a certain amount of data um
for the for the network or for the model
so for example the output of the
function on some new point x is it's
it's a probabilistic computation so it's
described by some distribution in this
case it's a normal distribution with a
mean and a variance that you can write
down analytically and for example the
mean is just gotten by Computing this
linear algebra um you know computation
on the T on the original targets why at
the data points that you have and doing
some linear algebra using this kernel
function that I described on the prior
slide so for every Network every neural
network that you have you have this
kernel function K you can compute it on
your training data just as you would for
other gaussian processes and then you
can use that to make predictions and so
this became a way of um obtaining basan
predictions that are exact from an infin
wide deep neural
Network and pictorially um for those of
you just as a maybe reminder of of ban
kind of methods and what a gaussing
process does um you know it's it's
probabilistic so before you learn from
data you have some kind of distribution
over the values of the function um uh
with some mean and some variance but
after you learn from data your function
kind of reduces its error around those
data points to match the values y that
it's regressing to and then there's some
remaining variants in the places in
input space where you don't have a lot
of data but you would need to um you
know have more constraints to to do
better
learning and so in summary this was kind
of a fewe program essentially to um take
neural networks of different
architectures so this zoo of
architectures that exists out there
um with all sorts of different models
and um derive in this uh large n limit
the gaussian process and kernels that
that um originate from those and we did
that at the very beginning with um our
very first paper on just the fully
connected neural network which gives
rise to some kernel K which I label FC
just to just to say that it it it's um
tied to the architecture of a fully
connected neural network you can do
something similar with a convolutional
neural network so these are often used
uh in vision problems um there the
notion of what is n what is the large
width limit is slightly different it's
the number of filters that you use but
again it's always corresponding to this
sequential process uh sorry parallel
processing that you're doing in every
layer at the same time you can also do
it for models with attention layers that
are now um used in you know it's kind of
like the backbone of language models you
can do it with residual networks that
have skip connections you can also do it
with graph neural networks um as well
and so um this kind of had a a number of
implications so I've focused here more
on the methodology that originate that
um uh was one of the consequences of
these mappings so now you have gaussian
processes and kernels that you can just
use and it turned out that they were um
at the time
state-of-the-art um Gan processes
compared to like older
traditional uh GPS um for example the
the fully connected one uh that we
published at the at the begin um some
time ago uh at the time was was uh like
a state-of-the-art um gpn same with
convolutional and again I think this uh
the the reason for this um is that it's
a richer class of kernels or GPS because
it has this compositional hcal
processing that comes from the neural
network that usual gaussian processes
with um simple kernels like radial like
gaussian kernels or you know radial
basis functions don't have so one aspect
of this as I mentioned was uh meth one
consequence of uh this program was
methodological so now we have these
methods um that we can use um
uh in liew of traditional gaussian
processes um the second which I won't go
into was it kind of gave rise on the
theoretical side to the to uh even more
work on these large width limits and so
there have been a lot of consequences
coming from that as well which I won't
get get into but but um some of those
highlights have been that the community
was able to actually solve for the
Dynamics of optimization exactly
in that limit so there are other very
closely related kernels that you can
write down and construct that describe
what happens under optimization in this
large width limit and so this has given
people um a theoretical handle on the
problem in that limit it also has given
rise to kind of a whole subfield in in
machine learning having to do with uh
setting um parameterizing networks layer
widths layers in in a right way so as to
either be close to this limit or not be
close to this limit and I won't get into
that either but just allude to this fact
that this has kind of gone off and and
evolved into other directions as well um
on the methodical side I'll say that um
so I talked more about the theory but if
you're interested in using um any of
these models uh there was sort of a
larger effort um at Google to um con
construct a library that would allow you
to easily Implement these kernels um and
gaussian processes uh kind of in um in
correspondence with neural network
layers so in the same way that we have
libraries for neural network layers
where we can Define you know a fully
connected layer or convolutional layer
and so on um now you can uh do that um
in a way to you can Define networks and
at the same time Define these kernels
and be able to compare them sort of
Apples to Apples um Jax is a really nice
um framework also developed at Google so
this Library the neural tangents library
is written in Jax um and it's very uh
easy to use um so I encourage everyone
to play around with it um you just
import its neural network library and
you can define a neural network here a
like a sequence for example of uh just
weight matrices and reu function
nonlinearities and be able to obtain
both the kernel function and the actual
neural network function train them and
then compare compare them and so we did
this also pretty systematically across
different
architectures um and for each case it
turns out that uh whether the finite
size neural network or the infinite with
kernel uh does better really depends on
the architecture and the and the type of
data so for example you may uh this
might run counter to your wisdom but um
in the case of fully connected neural
networks it turns out that that the
kernels do pretty well on like the
simple Benchmark data sets coming from
the the the vision you know very simple
uh image classification data sets um and
I think one reason for that is because
fully connected neural networks at
finite size are actually not very good
models they don't have Rich inductive
biases they don't have a lot of
structure that's actually relevant for
the physical world um and so the
infinite width neural network is
something that has infinitely many basis
functions in it and it actually does
either on par or as well you know as
well as the finite Siz neural network
now what we found was if you go to other
architectural class like convolutional
neural networks which do have structure
more structure in them that's well
suited for the physical world then the
finite siiz neural networks do do better
than the kernels um but it's also
important that you have enough data for
that to be true so a general um Trend
that um is now kind of known in the
field or um has kind of grown out of
that is is that these finite size neural
networks that
that we're all using today do do really
well but you do really need um a certain
amount of data for that to be true and
if you're in a low data regime you
actually it may not be the case that a
model which is infinitely large and is
just a kernel since that's a somewhat uh
it's a very particular class of models
uh a model that is just a kernel can
actually do that corresponds to the same
structure of the finite size neural
network work can actually do as well so
there's some crossover between as a
function of the amount of data that you
have between whether a kernel method is
good and whether a neural network um is
good so that's sort of a highlevel uh
takeaway from the systematic comparisons
of basically having a onetoone
correspondence between infinite size
models and their finite siiz versions
and their finite siiz versions when when
you know as I just reiterate when you do
have um Rich structure in the model that
matches that of the physical world the
finite size network does do better
because it adapts its basis functions to
the data and a kernel does not do
that I want can ask a quick question
like do how many parameters does this
equivalent caution process kernel have
like so because that seems to be the key
issue for data right so uh do you have
any um comment on that so it only has in
terms of tunable parameters these with
the hyper parameters it would have just
for example in these vanilla settings um
uh just the like a I didn't write it on
this slide I guess but a like a weight
variance and a bias variance so two
constants that come from sort of the
scale that you want to choose for your
prior on W and a scale for the prior on
the bees and a lot of the ones we tested
were kind of this they're essentially
two parameter gaussian processes then we
tune those two hyperparameters but the
neural network does have in principle a
few more design choices as well that we
tune okay okay and that that's where the
more data requirements come from you for
the neural
network um no the more data requirements
seem to come from well it it's actually
not well understood theoretically or
just why but it's more of an empirical
observation where if you're the the
thing with a kernel is that it
has
um if a neural network is allowed to
learn um yeah
if I guess that I guess I would agree
maybe that is a way of stating it um you
need more data to it's better if you can
adapt your basis functions quite a lot
to the data but in order to do that you
do need more data okay yeah that's sort
of the yeah May um maybe the the the
rough
idea
thanks um any other
questions I I don't see anyone hands up
so you can
so um so that kind of uh is just was an
overview of this area um uh in case you
want to read more about it or use some
of the tools um now I'll just switch
gears to a different um uh kind of more
recent Evolution which is uh trying to
understand scaling laws in um in machine
learning models in general but
particularly neural network models and
especially when they're large and so
I'll give a bit of an over review on
that um as well so um you know you have
these basic knobs in machine learning
that you can tune um to adjust the
performance of an ml model so amount of
training data that you have which is
often small and scientific applications
is is one of them but you also have the
size of the model as well as the amount
of time you want to train for um or
another way to state that is um you can
change units espe essentially and
instead study the amount of
computational resources you have to
devote to that so like the amount of
flops uh that you you would like in a
computation and um nowadays in the era
of at least in the in the space of um
very large machine learning models um
there were a few empirical observations
a few years ago that kind of just
highlighted um a a very simple Trend but
one that's very useful to measure which
is just that
uh the uh quality of your model as
measured by the test loss after training
um seems to improve uh rather
monotonically as a function of any one
of these uh variables in the problem so
the amount of um computational resources
you have the amount of training data and
the number of parameters and these
Trends uh sometimes although not always
uh seem to be like power laws with
certain exponents to that scale
um there are of course other knobs that
you can also tune which I won't discuss
uh like the quality of the data um how
heterogeneous it is and what mixtures
you should take um but for now I'll just
focus on these um uh empirical
observations um some other examples of
this which uh you might be familiar with
uh are uh also in the um uh in the space
of large language models so um you know
gpt3 um one of the things that was uh
originally observed about it was um that
you
know certain U performance benchmarks
can can improve monotonically as a
function of say the um size of the model
or the amount of data and so on but
there's other regimes um other uh uh
types of problems where you can have
sort of
discontinuous uh behavior um and so for
example um one of the observations was
if you take um let's say you take some
relatively smaller model and you look at
um the accuracy as a function of the
amount of examples that you give in
context to this model so now we're
thinking of language models they have
some they're trained on some
pre-training data set some Corpus but um
uh they can do in context learning so
after they're trained you can give them
some few examples um you know that's how
you interact with say chat G uh chat GPT
or any of these large language models
available now you give a few examples um
which is uh you know the number of
examples in context and you can look at
the how the performance improves as a
function of the number of examples in
the context and um sometimes what what
was well what was observed was that if
you um uh continue increasing the size
of the model uh there's a point at which
you actually get some discontinuous
behavior um as a function of the number
of examples in the context so for this
Ultra large almost absurdly large you
know uh model what you find is that the
accuracy uh uh as a function of the
amount of data in the context uh
improves um and then uh kind of
transitions to a to a different slope
but at large much larger values of the
accuracy as you give it more and more
examples so this is the kind of behavior
that at least model designers in this in
this other regime which I know is uh
somewhat different from scientific
applications which are much more small
scale um but this is sort of the regime
that people are working in nowadays in
the space of uh large language models or
even um models like Alpha fold and so on
which have a lot of training data and
and very large size um but uh there's a
lot of empirical work essentially to try
to figure out the best way to scale up a
model so if you have some amount of
resources that you want to devote to
training a model um uh let's say you
have a fixed amount of computational
resources that you're willing to spend
then there's an optimal way to allocate
that those resources uh to either to
some amount of you you should pick the
amount of training data that you need um
uh in a specific way and you can pick
the model size in a specific way and
there's some trade-off if your model for
example is too small relative to the
amount of data that you have then you
may not actually be getting uh all of
being able to EXT you're not able to
extract all the information that you
could from that data set or vice versa
if your training set is too small
relative to the size of your model you
don't actually have enough information
for the you know the the richness of the
model you have many more parameters that
you could be you using that you're not
essentially using so there is a bit of a
trade-off here and and the community uh
has been looking at um uh figuring out
the best ways to scale up so that it's
compute
optimal um I will't go too much into the
details of what we've looked at but we
we uh uh did some theoretical work um
essentially trying to analyze uh what
gives rise to these scaling laws what
what controls these Trends and this is
important for any model even in the
physical sciences so often you're
interested in the physical sciences is
in you have a fixed amount of data and
you just want to know how good is the
model right now the quality of the fit
but it could be that you're in this
situation maybe you're working with
experimentalists or something where you
could uh potentially obtain more data
over a time let's say and then the model
that you would want to choose is
actually not the model that has the best
fit right now it's the model that whose
rate of improvement is actually pretty
good as well so it's just another metric
to look at um because you might be able
to do more with with such a model if you
had just a little bit more data or just
a little bit bigger model uh in terms of
its
size so um I'll maybe just uh skip a bit
over this since it's maybe a bit um too
much kind of in the uh there's there
might be a question on the chat but I'll
I'll I'll I won't go into the details of
this just to say that we looked at this
problem theoretically um uh looking at
the loss as a function of the amount of
data D and for us the model size but it
was um related to the width of the
neural network and we were able to
derive these power laws um as a function
of the amount of data D or the model
size and they have certain exponents
which is what I'm highlighting in color
so that's telling you about this rate of
improvement Alpha D or Alpha
W um the short of it is is that one of
the things we found um which I can
summarize as a just highlevel rule of
thumb is that if you have if you're
looking at
scaling one of these parameters on its
own either the amount of data that you
have or the size of the model so D or
n there are different regimes of scaling
that kick in
so what hap what happens is that if
you're um scaling up if you have these
two variables D and the variable n
um one of them will be the bottle neck
in the scaling so let's say um it's it's
a very intuitive rule but um let's say
uh you're in this regime so um the
amount of data you have relative to the
size of the model where this constant is
not something we know but it's it's some
uh you know rough regime where where
this is true then if you look at the
data sit data say data set size scaling
D so what happens if my model is large
I'm um I have a certain amount of data
and I want to increase the amount of
what would happen if I increase the
amount of data you get some particular
exponent Alpha D we called this we gave
this this regime a name it's called
resolution limited it has to do with how
well you resolve the data manifold
essentially so this exponent Alpha D is
actually pretty complicated it depends
both on the data and the neural
architecture and I'll mention I'll give
some few examples of what controls this
power law um the exact same idea is true
if you now switch the roles of the
variables so now let's say you're in
this regime where you have a lot of data
you have a small model and you're just
looking at the what happens when you
scale the size of the model again the
model size is the bottl neck and you get
some
exponent Alpha W which is complicated in
general you one should go measure it um
but uh but it has to do with again this
resolution of of a data
manifold but if you're in this other
regimes which I'm in this table I'm
putting on the
diagonals so for example if you're in
this regime where uh you have a certain
model size and you have a lot of
training data if you keep increasing the
amount of data uh your exponent the rate
at which you improve is actually just
some fixed constant equal to one so the
gains you know from this are kind of uh
potentially marginal or not um and and
uh something similar happens when you
again reverse the two variables so at a
high level this is all just to say that
you can partition this space of 2D space
of data scaling and model scaling into
different regimes you can categorize
them and you can understand that certain
regimes are actually a quite related to
each other and B you can understand what
controls the scaling in those regimes
and then there are other regimes where
it really has to do with how well you
model the data manifold uh and so on so
these are just empirical results to kind
of demonstrate that we see these
exponents Alpha equal to one in these
diagonal regimes regardless of what the
problem is so these are like different
data sets different models they all
improve the same rate Alpha equal to one
same with this down here but on the off
diagonals which correspond to these
other regimes we see very problem
dependent exponents so that's sort of
the high level takeaway um I'll say one
final thing which is that the power laws
in these
regimes uh on the off off diagonals that
you have are actually related to power
laws that you see in the data so if you
take and this is maybe more details than
U uh something I'll get into but if you
take those kernels that I showed you
alluded to earlier in the beginning of
the talk um and if we want to just study
let's say the scaling of a gaussian
process or of a kernel method it turns
out you can understand that pretty well
and it's very related to um the
properties of the kernel when it's
evaluated on training
data so for example imagine
that I take one of the kernels let's say
the kernel from the fully connected
Network that I had earlier um in in in
the large width derivation and I just
want to understand uh what is the data
scaling of a model with that kernel like
what controls that um this is actually a
better understood problem and in this
case you can actually be pretty precise
about what controls it one of the big
factors is just the igen value spectrum
of that kernel
uh Matrix when you evaluate it on the
training data and if you look at real
data one of the properties unlike many
theoretical models is that one of the
properties it displays is that it has a
power law dependence so if I look at the
igen values Lambda I as a function of I
there's some power law Behavior as a
function of the index I of the Igan
value that power lot depends on the
difficulty of the data set and um the
structure of the kernel so here just to
tune the complexity of the data what
we're doing is core screening image data
so um so for example uh as as we go from
1 to 14 what we're doing is taking
images and a you know um uh uh course
graining them so just averaging them
locally until we produce images of lower
and lower resolution and that produces
uh that's as we uh go up to these pink
numbers and that changes the spectrum of
the kernel because it changes the
complexity of that data set and the task
that you have to perform which is
interpreting uh either a high resolution
image or a low resolution image so this
is all just to just to say that um or
highlight that these Hala models scales
it's scaling behavior and these power
laws um in some of these regimes where
it's very data dependent it depends on
the data manifold can be tied back to
Power laws that originate in real
natural data like the real world has
power Law data in it when you look at um
uh what it looks like in these
covariance functions or kernel
functions okay I'll um maybe skip over
some of the predictions
um that come there's there's more
details of of our Theory and what we
predict um but again the the takeaways
we can observe um these different
regimes with exponent Alpha equal to one
as well as exponents that are very
different and uh dependent on the
problem as you see here Alpha D that is
uh around 2 Alpha P again around point2
this is now on a setting which involves
pre-training and fine-tuning so it's a
pretty U practically relevant setting so
I'll skip over these I'll just say that
there's also these connections between
scaling and the dimensionality effective
dimensionality of the data manifold and
so um we've done we had done experiments
where we looked at the correlation
between the data scaling exponent and
the dimensionality of the data manifold
and um essentially Alpha d goes as one
over the effect
Dimension uh of the problem and you can
see for different data sets at least
there's a rough correlation in that um
uh the the larger the the
dimensionality uh the harder the problem
um and and the
scaling so um just a few other empirical
observations that might um interest you
again if if uh uh you were to to look at
scaling for any models that work with um
but modifying the task affects the
scaling um of course uh so um for
example let me point to this example on
the right if you corrupt data with
noise then um it becomes more difficult
and the scaling of that same model as
you increase the noise so those are the
kind of the blue numbers the scaling uh
uh worsens both the num both the curves
shift up words but their slope also
changes so the efficiency of the model
on that data set is much worse on the
other hand if you actually just change
the task to be something that's kind of
semantically very similar to the
original task you don't change the
efficiency uh at least Within These
experiments you just shift the um um
curves up and
down um you can also look at
architectural differences within uh
certain families of Neal Network model
so this is like a very classic ml setup
where you have a wide reset model um
it's a family of models that you can
make deeper or wider and you can look at
the scaling uh on uh real data sets and
um what you find is depth again kind of
roughly shifts the curves up and down
but if you change the
width uh quite a lot and as you make the
network wider it actually uh has a worse
slope actually this is connected to what
I mentioned earlier about the the
efficiency of kernels compared to neural
network models um what these curves
essentially are doing is uh the pink one
is say a neural network model of a
particular width and as we um increase
the width we actually get closer to
these kernel regimes and kernels don't
scale as efficiently as neural networks
once you have enough data and you can
see that wor efficiency here um data
efficiency in in this blue uh
line finally I'll just mention that um
another uh kind of very connected
emerging area um is how can we how can
you do better than the power laws that
you have um that are kind of fixed
you're stuck with depending on the model
that you choose and your data set and um
there it's known that you could beat
these scaling laws the power law form if
you subselect your data in a very
strategic manner so if like somehow you
knew which data would be the right ones
to select you could actually get this
kind of
sigmoidal um Improvement as a function
of the amount of data um it levels off
at some point but for very small data
sets that means that it's much better to
actually um you know strategically
subselect the data
rather than use all the data that you
have kind of randomly sampled IID from
from your set and so figuring out the
way to do this is sort of a it's a um
continuing area of research but
something to to keep in mind especially
when you um when you are in these data
limited regimes or you can you know
wisely choose um the data or where to
sample um if you're doing Active
Learning and so on um in these in these
settings okay um so maybe just to
summarize kind of the two portions of
this talk um and thanks for your uh
patience and interest because this was
more focused on sort of like what are
the foundational principles we kind of
understand um on uh on uh of neural
networks and and ml at the moment and I
just wanted to kind of reiterate these
two which was the first was that neural
architectures very general class of
neural network models different
architectures all naturally give rise to
gaussian processes and Rich
compositional kernels that can be useful
as methods they're more useful in low
data regimes where traditionally gassian
processes and kernels are used um I
think if you're going to if you do use
such models it's worth considering these
compared to compared to traditional Gan
processes with traditional kernels
because there's a good chance um these
might do pretty well for your
application um uh like one one other
difference in addition to the
compositionality that I actually forgot
to mention is that these kernels um are
non-local kernels you know local kernels
um like a natural radial basis function
so it it it gives larger weight to to
inputs in the feature space that are
closer together um but neural networks
and their Associated kernels are in some
ways um more powerful models because it
allows you to give a correlation a
similarity to features that are
potentially very different in their
original input space even though they're
similar in some higher dimensional
nonlinear space so nonlocality is
actually another um way in which these
kernels are different than kind of
traditional kernels um they can be
useful for beian modeling if you want
principled uncertainty estimates um or
marginal likely likelihood estimates and
so on and then the second uh topic that
I talked about was thinking about
scaling laws so kind of just the
changing perspective from not just how
well does the model do right now with my
fixed setting of a fixed amount of data
and a fixed model size but if I change
these knobs just a little bit um uh
Which models are actually more efficient
and if I could get to that regime then
they would actually be better model
model so that as a is another angle for
model comparison um and then also
thinking about data selection strategies
so that you can uh scale better than the
kind of default power law scaling that
um that you would have if you if you
just sampled data randomly
IIT and with that um think I will just
thank you for your interest and that
kind of wraps up everything I wanted to
um to tell you about um today thank you
fantastic uh yes man um wonderful talk
um you know but we have a quick
questions um I don't know you can see
that or not but uh let's start from the
's questions um El if you are there um
would you mind you you know unmute
yourself and ask your
questions if not I can it's the s from
when you talk about the scaling low uh
he was asking is the S foam really the
optimal he was asking how about the
product power low like product phone
instead of the S phone oh can um is
there a chance to see the questions
actually is yes well there is a if you
go to the top of the yes there's a
options on the
top and
then there's a chat yes yes
if you open that window then you will
see all
the all the questions in the chat I see
okay you see that yes great okay cool
yeah uh let's start from the
ills the very first one is asking is the
S form really the optimal fix about a
product that's a great question it may
not be so what people have observed is
usually um in in a lot of the regimes
that they've studied think the dominant
ones are first the sums like first you
treat them semi-independently but there
might be correction terms that have to
do with this product so by no means is
is the form that I wrote down kind of
the the um ground truth tried in True
Form um it's more like functional fits
that people have done and for certain
problems it might be that indeed um
adding that product form uh is actually
uh very important and and very good fit
it just seems to be the case that for a
lot of these cases the additive form is
is is kind of a dominant good fit
natural B okay all right next question
is by Cole he's asking could you comment
on the diverent behavior in the bottom
left figure of the
taxonomy you know what he's talking
about four figures I yes I think this
one yes it looks like the power lows
divers from the data as one scales to
larger width which is different from the
other figures that show continuing
improvements yes that's also a a great
observation great question um it's it's
actually just an artifact of this
experiment so um this experiment is kind
of done really these regimes that I've
talked about are kind of ASM totic
regimes we don't have a lot of control
when n is of the order of D so there's
this crossover that happens in between
these two regimes and that crossover
regime is actually um described kind of
known to be described by double desent
like phenomenon if for example your
model is not very well regularized so
what you what you should focus on I
think for the theory agreement is just
uh um this left part uh of the of the
experiment um because this is trying to
be in a regime where um n is much
smaller than d
but just as a artifact of our
experiments we had finite amount of D so
there's a point at which n Becomes of
order D and then um we wouldn't observe
power loss scaling we see a crossover to
a different Behavior so actually all of
these curves are kind of um
uh uh what what what you would uh
actually observe is like this is sort of
one half of uh one portion of a regime
the there's a crossover that happens and
you would actually uh end up in this
regime if you were on the other side of
that
crossover makes sense makes sense thank
you very much cool okay next question is
by Peter perhaps the alpha D to Alpha W
transition is a function of a variance
of the data versus variance of the model
parameters what do you think about that
um I I'm not quite sure what the alpha D
to Alpha W transition is is it um
describing this
transition Peter if you are there if you
can clarify your question just unmuted I
don't know if you can hear me yeah we
can hear you yeah great thank you um
yeah I I just uh I have limited
experience in this field so I'm I may be
saying things that don't make any sense
but it seems to me uh you're you're in
you're going from one domain to another
with these you know with the difference
differences and it seems like the
variance certainly the variance in the
data is going to
affect how well these things perform and
you alluded to that I think it's some of
your other slides but there's
also uh the way the model
is defined and
how good your model is in terms of
matching the real physics of the model
there's going to be there's going to be
variances in the in the um model
parameters as well and I would I would
think that that that so what I'm trying
to say is I could imagine a situation
where you have a very good bottle and
there really isn't a lot of variance in
the model parameters you just have to
figure out what they are and if you have
enough and but you got a bunch of
variants in your data and if you get
enough the more and more data you get
the Tighter and Tighter your your model
gets to predicting the model
parameters um and then and then the
other end of that regime is
uh you um you're very good at measuring
your your your
um your data you have very little
uncertainty in your
data uh so vice versa to what I just
said sorry I I don't know I mean I'm I'm
just throwing that out
there no the that's also a great
question um so a couple points so I I
think the variance that you're alluding
you you alluded to maybe things that I
would separate so there's uh like the
variance of the data coming from uh the
fact that uh you subselected some amount
of data there so it's like a finite
batch there's a size to it maybe you
also have uncertainty in your regression
targets that's also a source of variance
these things um uh there's also another
source of variance from model parameters
coming from the choice of initialization
and randomness of the
optimization um so each time you run an
optimization and you choose the
initialization so on you may get a
slightly different model so these
sources of variance are actually both in
the theory and these experiments have
been sort of averaged out so if I go
back to the way I kind of defined my
setup model model error versus data
error that's really what I'm go where
I'm going to with this and I think
that's what you're trying to to explain
here I I hope uh so how they relate
to it's actually um we actually don't I
think touch about touch on that too much
so the way I kind of defined I didn't go
into this but we are in our Theory
problem and many of these other Theory
problems we average out over those other
sources of variance so expectation over
D here means averaging over the draws of
a finite size d capital D samples so I
pick different batches and that those
have different variances but I'm going
to average over that to get at least
understand the average effect I'm also
going to average over the choice of
random
initialization um and in the experiments
what we're doing and you're you're right
that if you went out and just measured
we we do do a little bit of this
averaging um to produce these empirical
results so like you would do multiple
runs from different initializations we
draw different batches of data so we can
match uh you know so we can have some
connection to the theory if you went out
right now and ran a model um uh with you
know if you tried to do this experiment
what you would find are are are plots
that our curves that actually do have a
lot more Randomness in them because of
that now especially in kind of smaller
scale smaller data smaller model size
regimes now in these other settings like
large language models um the models and
the data set sizes are so large that
essentially they become self-
aaging so they when they run like if
they were to look at the variance
between different runs they don't see a
lot of Randomness so there is um
depending on the absolute sizes of these
things the amount of data and the model
size there is this Randomness or a
variance that I've averaged out over
here and you would observe um uh and and
that matters as well and you're totally
right to to ask about that but there's a
second U part to your question where you
said like how well does the model fit to
uh the data kind of an alignment does
the model have the right inductive bias
does it align well to the data and
that's the question that we're trying to
get at uh in this um in in this work and
and others in theory so like there you
you want to average just to even
understand that problem you want to
average out all the other sources of
Randomness and even there the the value
of alpha D and Alpha W um in these two
regimes that I mentioned uh on the off
diagonal kind of categorizations or
table
they do depend on this alignment it's
it's essentially a a how well uh your
model aligns to the data and in this
kernel setting there's actually a
precise notion of
that okay I to to paraphrase what you
just
said uh well I'm not exactly sure but I
I I I I I understand where you're going
I'm not sure I understand how it the
implications for the various variables
but so when when you're in a
the worse I guess what I'd like to the
question I want to ask is the the better
your model
is the better your model fits the actual
data how does that change that it sounds
like that reduces the the the alpha D or
the alpha W am I getting that right it
it uh increases it so it's there's a
steeper slope in
general there's there's an addition
there's a constant shift to all of these
that we can't these are oh yeah Alpha is
the power law parameter Al is the power
law yeah so that would make sense it
would the higher the increase the
steeper the slope the better you get
okay yeah so that's true and that amount
of alignment so the the constant shifts
we can't say much about there um
theoretically but at least the
efficiency the the rate of improvement
so the slope of these lines uh does is
governed by some notion of alignment
between the model and the data and
actually in the setting of kernels or
gaussian processes you can that's that's
now well understood it it is actually
literally like an alignment between the
regression values and igen vectors of
this
Matrix um and so these would be these
are actually things that you could
measure ahead of time just to kind of
have an assessment at least for kernels
and Gan processes how well they you know
whether they're good models for the data
simply by looking at the these igen
values and looking at the igen vectors I
I think are you saying that you could
use potentially use this to as an
assessment of the quality of your model
for for kernels and gaussian processes I
think you could um for neural network
models there isn't an exact because of
these actual so this all is kind of
based on these infinite width results
that I mentioned um so but for for
finite with neural networks there's no
such kind of a exact notion there's
maybe some puristic that are similar
that you could use okay thank you yeah
thank you thank you Peter um and thank
you Yan for answering the question and
next do you have a time by the way y
it's I do okay awesome okay the next
question is by Kevin is there a way to
initialize weights and bias of a finite
sized neural network so that it
approximates GP conal with desire
highper
parameters oh that's a good um
interesting question question um so if
you take the finite sized Network
already and you just um choose the you
can choose the initialization of the
weights and the biases so there are
these um variances Sigma squ W Sigma squ
B that I didn't write down but I alluded
to those show up in the kernel as well
if you choose those to be the same then
the finite size network with finite siiz
hidden layers already you could use
those feature vectors to construct the
kernel and it would be like a finite
size approximation to the kernel it may
not be the optimal one so there might be
actually mathematically smarter things
that you could do but it is true that if
you took those if you just took for
example the um representations of a
randomly initialized neural network um
uh of finite size and took those feature
vectors and used them to construct like
a covariance matrix it would be like a
it would be some um uh like a kernel
Matrix that Matrix as you make the width
larger is exactly the kernel so um that
is a finite size approximation of it I
guess you can use that as a initial
weights and bias and then let it train
with the final size of the neural net
whatever the data you have
that might be a
strategy well
that I guess so for a GP um for the for
the neuronet not the GP but you could
you maybe say the question would you
like to train the neural network in a
different way yeah I mean you start with
a weights and bias which is
corresponding to the GP conel with the
desired hyper parameter and they use
that and as a initial Gess of we and
bias
and then uh train them using U you know
the data you have oh so so figure out
this is like figure out the optimal
hyperparameters weight and biases from
the
GP yeah exactly use that yeah motivated
by the GP yes yeah you you could do you
you could do that I I actually suspect
it might not make too much of a
difference as long as you're there are
some pretty good regimes of weight and
bias variances for neural networks that
have been calculated and as long as
you're kind of in that regime so nothing
too kind of pathological a lot of neural
networks end up uh giving good results
at least if you have enough data and the
model size is large enough so I suspect
performance- wise it might not have a
big effect um but but you certainly
could do that right Kevin do you have a
followup
question
um I think I think that's a good of uh
explanation thank you so much okay uh
next question is by Hana
Nelson um she's saying I interpreted the
graphs as being in terms of train eror
should we expect similar scaling results
on data which is outside our Collective
data that's a great question yeah so
these graphs were the were um uh
plotting the the test error but but they
it's true that they um the the
evaluation and the training data are
from the same distribution so it's an in
distribution setting and if you um we're
going to look at the test error on out
of distribution data um so many Works
have done that um uh they do see um
scaling laws uh but it it actually they
they can get very different kinds of
behavior so sometimes you know when the
data it really just depends on the outof
distribution data and how well it aligns
to the like pre-trained trained model so
there are cases where it improves with
these other scaling variables but maybe
after a certain scale it actually gets
worse um sometimes it just improves
monotonically sometimes it gets worse
monotonically so there's been all sorts
of um uh kind of uh types of behaviors
observed um and it's a great thing to do
I think um but it's really there there
isn't much control uh on
it okay and um she also has another
comment or question yeah oh she says
this is test data yes
okay
um okay she's saying the more parameters
doing better with a scaling things
reminds me of accuracy Boost from boost
St aggregations in three
classifiers another question from her
I've seen it thrown around that the
curves of graphs of training loss can be
used to approximate the dimension of the
manifolds of the distributions we are
trying to learn in your opinion is this
a sound
practice um I think it's going to be a
pretty noisy estimate unless maybe
there's a specific setting that you're
thinking of where there are some like
rigorous or semi rigorous results um I
kind of the plots that I showed where
there was a correlation between the
exponent and some measurement of the
data manifold which I also didn't
specify or get into the details of was
sort of loose um I think estimates of
manifold dimensionality are um uh are
tricky to get right um and and kind of
noisy on their own and so um I think
also the relationship between those two
can be um maybe not super robust unless
there's maybe a spefic specific setting
that you're thinking of to to my
knowledge awesome okay I have a
questions um I have a tons of questions
I I was fascinated by your geian process
cono you know the method um but let me
ask another questions related to the you
know the slide you showed um introducing
as a active research area right now
about by choosing certain uh training
dat data uh selectively you can get much
better scaling laws yeah and that one
that's um is very attractive to us
especially because the da data we are
getting uh is usually associated with a
high fidelity you know the computational
model simulations and you know just
getting one data is is very costly so we
we want to choose those you know the
training data very wisely so that when
we train the either neural network or
gaan model or some other data trib
approach we would like to you know get
the much better scaling L convergence
right with the as few as data as
possible and since those data is coming
from physics simulations we can utilize
this a lot of like the physical prior
knowledge right um you know the
conservation of low um each physics has
a on uh the basics property to satisfy
what would be your Insight like um you
know do you think you know using those
domain Knowledge from the physics side
and bringing into those sampling um you
know training data sampling procedure um
will will be essential to give us a this
know much better scaling or convergence
Behavior ABS absolutely yeah I think I I
do think that in um
and uh in low data regimes and and small
models certainly the more um inductive
the more intuition you put into it I
think the better in general it can do um
I wouldn't I wouldn't I think it's kind
of a really an ongoing question what are
the best heuristics to use even on the
ml side um so so yeah I would say I I
think I would trust personally if I were
working in a domain I I knew well I
would trust my intuition actually for
how to do that subsampling at the moment
I can say that um in these regimes often
uh well there are a number of charistics
out there since this paper was published
but one thing that people have been
doing is um kind of kind of in a ways
it's a form of cheating because and I
think this is what this paper had done
which was kind of um use a large there
was a larger model that was trained on
this data set that was used to suggest
kind of um to pick the example so maybe
the places where there was greatest
error I don't quite remember the the
metric but one of the catches was um and
in a lot of large scale ml settings they
kind of um one of the catches is that
they might have already access to some
large model to point them to uh uh to
which subset they might want to keep and
then they might build something like a
foundation data set so just pruning the
DAT the original data set that is let's
say a benchmark data set that everybody
uses to some subsampled um set um that
is then fixed and and others would use
that to train on and one of the things
that's been kind of observed is that um
maybe a lot of models at least in these
other like kind of mainstream ml
communities that are used kind of share
um they have similar Notions of what is
a good example or a hard example you
know a hard example or an easy example
so that therefore the mo the large model
that is sort of like a teacher can kind
of point it can that signal that you
would use from a larger model that is
like a teacher is actually useful for a
smaller model but this might not
transfer across domains and so on so
this is one of the ways that people have
been kind of getting around this um uh
by by kind of bootstrapping and kind of
using this having access to this teacher
model to produce that pruned data set
that then is actually pretty good for
small models that you would then train
on with fewer data uh with fewer
samples all right well thank you yasan
for the wonderful talk and as well as
you know the wonderful the QA sessions I
I think we have to let you go we want to
keep you longer but I you know know uh
we we would like to respect your your
schedule too uh so we are so happy that
uh you uh came to us and then gave a
wonderful talk and you know uh give us
chance to discuss things um hopefully
after this um if you allow maybe the
collaboration is is encouraged um then
we can actually do the collaborations on
some of the scientific discovery through
this cion and wonderful research on this
neurom talk scaling law
uh is it do you think it's a oh yes I'm
I'm I'm happy to to chat further and
discuss okay okay yeah please audience
um please reach out to Dr Bari and uh um
for the future collaboration I will do
uh myself um you know for the future
collaboration reach out to you okay with
that uh let's end our seminar today and
it was wonderful
seminar okay let
me push the stop button for the record